كنت تخبرني كيف أردت
دراجة بخارية من سانتا
كيف كنت تريد دراجة بخارية لعيد الميلاد ،
هذا صحيح ،
نعم تريد الدراجات البخارية
هذه ديلا البالغة من العمر 14 عامًا ولدت
بحالة وراثية نادرة
تؤثر على قدرتها على التحدث لم نفعل
أدركت حقًا أنه كانت هناك مشكلة
حتى كانت تدور حول واحدة ولم تكن
تلبي معالمها ، لذا من الصعب
الجلوس زاحفًا ، لاحظنا أيضًا
أنه لم يكن هناك خطاب إنها
غير لفظية تمامًا
تريد أن تذهب لركوب القطار الذي
لديه شقيق ديلا آرتشر  كان يطور
تطبيق ويب لمساعدة أخته على
التواصل ، فهي تريد التواصل
مثل أي شخص آخر
وتخيل فقط مدى
صعوبة التواصل من خلال التحدث إلى
الأشخاص ، حيث يتيح موقع الويب للمستخدمين برمجة الأزرار
بصور من اختيارهم
تمثل الكلمات i
مثلك
شذرات ، حسنًا
القطار ، نعم ، سنذهب إلى القطار ،
سنذهب إلى القطار في الماضي
عندما اضطررنا إلى أداء المهمات التي أخذناها للتو
لم تكن أبدًا  استشر lly
وأعني الآن أن نزهات اليوم تبدأ معنا
فقط نسأل ، هل تريد أن تذهب ، هل
تريد أن تذهب ، أفعل ذلك ،
نعم ، أريد أن أفعل ذلك
الاختيار
الذي تريده بسرعة ،
أريد أن أذهب أسرع ، تريد أن تذهب
بشكل أسرع
في كل مرة قدمت فيها التطبيق لأول مرة ،
قضيت ما يقرب من ساعة إلى ساعتين في
طلاء لوحة البلاط لها
والتأكد من أنها تحتوي على جميع الأزرار والأشياء المفضلة لديها
والتي أتذكرها مثلما أعطيتها
لها ، وضعتها على جهاز iPad الخاص
بها وفتحته  وقلت كما لو كنت تعرف شيئًا أو
شيئين ثم أغلقته
وشاهدت ما كانت تشاهده مثل كل
هذا كان بمثابة هذا
التفاعل الصغير ولكنه كان مشكلة كبيرة بالنسبة لي أو
رؤيتها تتواصل مع طلبي ،
أريد أن يكون لدى الجميع
لحظة من هذا القبيل مع
شقيقهم أو صديقهم غير اللفظي ، لذلك لدي
شقيق غير لفظي الآن حيث يقال إن
الكثير من التطبيقات في متجر التطبيقات
المصممة للأشخاص الذين لا يستطيعون التحدث
باهظة الثمن للغاية ولهذا السبب
جعل آرتشر له  التطبيق مجاني لأي شخص
لاستخدامه عندما i  لقد صنعت أول فيديو لي لأول مرة ،
كنت
أتوقع فقط أن يستقبلك تعرف عدد
قليل من الوفيات و 100 مشاهدة عندما
تلقى مليون مشاهدة ، تلقيت الكثير من
التعليقات الكثير من التعليقات التي
تهنئني وفي الأصل لأنني
كنت مطورًا مبتدئًا وعرفت
لقد شعرت نوعًا ما بهذا الإحساس
بمتلازمة المحتال ، الجزء الجيد عنها ، كما
تعلمون ، لقد حصلت على الكثير من مقل العيون في
المشروع وأنت تعلم أن لدي الكثير من
المساهمين الذين أرادوا المساهمة
في آرتشر الكود الخاص بهم جعل برامجه مفتوحة
المصدر مما يعني  يمكن للمبرمجين الآخرين إضافة
ميزات جديدة إلى التطبيق اليوم ، وسأوضح
لنا كيف يمكننا التحكم في حرية
الكلام بأعيننا فقط على iPad
باستخدام تطبيق رائع يسمى
hawkeye access ، وسأنظر بعد ذلك إلى
كلمة hello hello blink
أثناء التطبيق  لا يزال عملاً
قيد التقدم ولا يمكن الوصول إليه إلا من
خلال موقع ويب ،
فهو يساعد بالفعل الأشخاص في جميع أنحاء
أمريكا والعالم في العثور على أصواتهم الخاصة
بحقيقة أنه متحمس لمساعدة
الأشخاص الآخرين الذين يستقبلهم
في  التعليقات التي تلقوها أنه يأخذها
في الاقتراحات ، وهذا ما يريده أي والد
لابنهم ، يريدون
أن يكبر طفلهم ليكون متعاطفًا
، والآن ها هو بطريقة ملموسة جدًا
لمساعدة الآخرين
[موسيقى]
وولف بليتزر سي إن واشنطن